Well, one of the definitions is that condition of a state...
...where the happiness of another is essential to one's own.
I think love is just a form of God.
Well, if you're talking family wise it means everything,...
...but if you're talking marriage, I mean you could be single,...
...and that's kinda what I want to do.
Wow, love is deep.
You know, you're asking the wrong age group...
...because the first thing I want to do is say love means never having to say you're sorry.
Love means never having to say you're sorry,...
...but I don't believe that at all cause I feel like you say you're sorry a lot.
Love to me is the greatest marketing campaign ever invented.
Love for me is being 100% vulnerable and all the way in you know.
You can love yourself first.
Once you learn how to love yourself, you can love anything in this world.
Someone that loves you, loves you because you're you.
Love means accepting people the way they are.
It has to be a two-way street.
It can't just be, I'm accepting you, you got to accept me too.